una fuente de inspiración para el mundo
así definió antonio gutiérrez secretario
general de las naciones unidas el
proceso de paz colombiano
el funcionario se refería al más
reciente informe de la misión de
verificación de la onu el último antes
del quinto aniversario de la firma del
pacto entre gobierno y la guerrilla de
las farc sin embargo el líder también
habló de las insuficientes medidas para
evitar asesinatos de ex combatientes
activistas y líderes sociales las
diversas disposiciones del acuerdo final
sobre garantías de seguridad se están
implementando de manera desigual lo que
conduce a acciones que resultan
insuficientes para frenar la violencia
el informe reporta el asesinato de 292
firmantes de paz desde noviembre de 2016
un tercio se han producido en tres
departamentos valle del cauca cauca y
nariño la onu también advirtió de la
necesidad de acceso a oportunidades para
ex combatientes como este festival
emprende paz organizado conjuntamente
por víctimas y ex guerrilleros sin
embargo cerca del 50% de los 13 mil 608
firmantes no se han beneficiado de
proyectos productivos esto ha aumentado
de disidentes de la guerrilla que han
retomado las armas que se calculan en
2500 violencia que está aumentando los
desplazamientos como denuncia a la
comisión interamericana de derechos
humanos
la comisión reitera que el
desplazamiento interno forzado
constituye una violación continua y
múltiple de los derechos humanos la cdh
que pide más medidas al estado se hace
eco del último informe de la onu para la
coordinación de asuntos humanitarios que
advierte que los desplazamientos han
aumentado un 135 por ciento respecto al
mismo periodo en 2020 esto en un país
considerado por acnur como el que más
desplazados internos tiene del mundo con
83 millones de personas